when you say there were deputized what
exactly does that mean so say I profited
from the 9/11 disaster and I place a
trade through you you were my broker
yeah
and the police came to you mmm feds came
to you said we are hereby deputize you
you could not tell anybody in the entire
world
anything you knew about that transaction
of white you would be thrown in prison
have you have you published any anything
on this on the 911 I've got videos on it
okay you can actually see the clip that
made headline news if you put in like
911 options trading insider options
trading on YouTube ah the news headline
clip is still out floating around
YouTube you see it's got to be terrorist
trade in the only way these transactions
could have gone through blah blah blah
and then completely disappears up there
is black oh wow man that is [ __ ] wild
what what is your view on 9/11 what is
your overall opinion on 9/11 why it went
down so the fact that people were
placing bets on the ER lines told me
that there was a grand conspiracy to
allow it to happen and to profit from it
and ultimately what they would get we
got the Patriot Act
we got endless wars in the Middle East
we got a record amount of defense
spending and I'm gonna interview some
people on the coronavirus subject about
what might happen when this pandemic
goes away will this change the world
permanently in the way that 9/11 changed
the world permanently in these draconian
measures such as the Patriot Act and all
the techno spying entered our lives so
do you think there's any chance that
there's any kind of legitimate inside
you know
see regarding the coronavirus like is
there any shadow of a doubt and shadow
of a doubt in your mind that it could
have been you know done on purpose by
the Chinese government or any government
whatsoever so in my early videos I was
saying that it was irrelevant where it
came from
yeah the important thing was to prepare
yourself right of course after
interviewing dr. Cottrell and looking
more closely at the level for bioweapons
lab in Wuhan and understanding these
coronaviruses were being experimented on
I can't eliminate the possibility that
it was leaked accidentally or on purpose
I like to hope that if it was a leak it
came accidently and it does seem to have
taken world leaders by surprise so I
would say right now I'm 80% zone attic
and 20% bio lab okay 20% that it was
developed for warfare but accidentally
leaked I'm 80% from animals from nature
right right right
wow that's scary scary times you know
Jordan these times I mean are you not
like contacting your family and loved
ones more right now and seeing
everyone's okay yeah it's the craziest
thing now is everybody's out riding
their bikes around town everyone's
outside jogging walking their dogs
people realize they people realize they
own dogs now and they actually take them
out for walks and it's like the opposite
of what it used to be like with everyone
glued to their phones
it's weird things like this make people
appreciate life and what we've got when
the shocks over and people adapt I'm
hearing from people you know I'm at home
I'm studying something I wanted to study
for years but never had the chance to do
it I'm learning a language so came a
turning point in incarceration for me
the first year I was wild you know would
have gone back to the lifestyle after
facing the 200 year maximum sentence
where I was on the brink of killing
myself pushed to the brink of suicidal
insanity
I let go of that material attachment my
million dollar house my plasma screen TV
my swimming pool my jacuzzi
none of that [ __ ] mattered anymore right
getting sentence nine and a half years
is one the happiest days of my life and
that taught me the happiness is not
material world it's in your thoughts and
in your heart mm-hmm so you can wake up
and appreciate the small things there's
no dead rats in my food anymore
there's no cockroaches in my bed you
know and that becomes a yardstick then
so if you're going through something
some form of hardship in your life where
it's kora virus or anything else
ask yourself while the toughest things
you ever got from your life and compare
and contrast if you've never been
through anything so tough watch my clip
about the cockroaches and yeah waking up
and your beds full of insects
definitely definitely have you been what
have you been doing personally with your
time besides obviously you're spending a
lot of time doing interviews whatever
but what have you been done personally
like with your health or with your diet
or whatever it may be to say say a
little bit so I'm trying to balance that
out now and I'm doing the yoga in the
house watching a bit of Netflix relaxing
reading my Kindle but as the strike zone
I'm gonna have to start doing more
physical things I'd like to start
jogging I've got beautiful countryside
behind me yeah I've been fattening the
squirrels up for months throwing them
all these nuts and stuff and I realized
now if you know if it is zombie
apocalypse I'm looking at recipes for
like squirrels chew yeah you watch those
things since the mystery meats lot with
the dead rats in it I'm vegetarian you
meeting tons of fruits and the top
doctors are saying vitamin C and vitamin
D and doing like lung exercises having
that long strength because smokers again
now buy this as well
[Laughter]